sie wissen alle digitalen zeitalter wird
alles anders
aber die frage ist eigentlich in welcher
hinsicht und ich schaue mir ein phänomen
an um das sich auch jörg müller und
johann geiger gefragt angefragt haben
nämlich das lesen der umgang mit büchern
also einen real phänomen und ich bin
hier ganz in der linie auch mit frau
krämer nicht in die richtung der kultur
philosophie gehen zu wollen sondern
tatsächlich schien zu gucken was sich
hier erinnern könnte mit maschinen lesen
gibt es also computergestützte wege des
lesens und was verändert sich hier
eigentlich nur der übliche weg den sie
wahrscheinlich alle kennen ist die klage
über das ende des buches wie sie zum
beispiel vom börsenverein des deutschen
buchhandels 2018 mit großer
aufmerksamkeit publiziert wurde
dort hat man festgestellt dass dem
buchmarkt deutlich leserschaft verloren
geht und zwar vor allem die jüngeren und
das ist in dieser qualifikation die
gruppe der unter 49 jährigen das ist
sehr großzügig ausgelegt die
offensichtlich in millionen nicht mehr
bücher kaufen und diese nachricht hat
das natürlich auch in die 'tagesschau'
gepackt hier sehen sie noch mal so ein
paar zahlen es reicht hier die roten -
zahlen zu gucken und sie sehen das buch
findet offensichtlich keine käufer mehr
so weit ist es eigentlich durchaus
üblich über dieses thema zu sprechen in
der öffentlichkeit wenn man ein bisschen
unter die motorhaube des buchhandels
guckt sieht die situation schon ganz
anders aus ich zitiere hier nur markus
dohle den ceo von pinkeln random house
das ist also der größte publikums verlag
der welt und der hat 2017 auf der
frankfurter buchmesse
mit aller deutlichkeit gesagt das
globale buchgeschäft erlebt die beste
zeit seit seinem bestehen also seit mehr
als 500 jahren ist doch erstaunlich dass
die binnensicht so stark von der
außensicht dirigiert und man könnte hier
argumentieren naja ist eines lobbyismus
nach außen und nach innen weiß man sehr
wohl dass das mit den büchern noch lange
nicht zu ende ist möchte ihnen in zwei
schritten zu diesem feld etwas vortragen
nämlich einige daten zu lesen was tut
sich da und dann vor allem der frage
nachgehen ob die maschinen und das lesen
die das beides eben zusammenhängen
könnte und ob die maschinen unser lesen
übernehmen gut beginnen wir mit daten
zum lesen
tatsächlich gibt es eine reihe von
studien und ich gebe hier nur ein paar
überblicksartikel studien wieder hier in
diesem fall zum lesen in den usa im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert seit den
80er jahren seitdem in jedem
amerikanischen haushalt ein fernseher
steht und nicht nur im haushalt sondern
fast jeden zehn zimmer ist die zahl der
menschen die überhaupt ein buch gelesen
haben mindestens einmal im jahr konstant
gefallen
in dem mit dem beginn des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts gilt es
sowohl für die jüngeren wie für die
älteren ändert sich das und zwar wie
auch diese dieser bericht beschrieben
ist aus dem jahr 2009
reading the new chapter in american city
also genau in dem moment in dem das
internet und der computer in unseren
alltag eintritt verändert sich etwas
es wird mir gelesen also zum ersten mal
seit mehreren jahrzehnten liest
mindestens die hälfte der amerikaner ein
buch pro jahr
das ist ein kulturpolitisch wichtiger
moment besonders jüngere menschen lesen
wieder also diejenigen die stereotyp
immer als bisher
das literat betrachtet werden auch die
absolute zahl der leser steigt in den
usa denn die amerikanischen bevölkerung
ist in den letzten drei dekaden
erheblich gewachsen um mehrere millionen
und im jüngsten bericht auf den
vollständig da ist der jetzt aber dann
wahrscheinlich 21 noch kommt vom manager
wird konstatiert und jetzt wird uns die
zu fotos teilen des services trading
range für perry and place
das müsste vision performing arts
batteries das so groß in der tendenz
surgery den bus experience bei teamworx
demographic krebs also ausgerechnet pool
sie lesen nimmt auch noch zu also das
standard genre eigentlich wo von dem man
annimmt dass es nicht mehr gelesen werde
weil es ein ganz besonders intensives
verhältnis zu buch zur sprache zu texten
voraussetzt
und genau das würde zu nehmen nun ist
das nicht die einzige studie der
economist hat zusammen mit dem pew
research center einer der wichtigsten
adressen für viele
sozialwissenschaftliche studien in den
usa ein argument aufgenommen dass sprit
es alles ist erlassen
aufgegriffen hatte er behauptet hat die
junge generation würde nicht mehr lesen
sie würde auch keine bücher mehr
schreiben über das nicht mehr für die
literatur interessieren im weitesten
sinne
und sie haben geguckt wie eben
amerikanische erwachsene was sie ob sie
in den letzten zwölf monaten nach
altersgruppen sortiert überhaupt
entweder ein buch in jedem format ein
gedrucktes buch ein ebook oder in
augsburg zu überhaupt konsumiert haben
und hier zeigt sich eigentlich genau das
umgekehrte bild was die übliche
kulturkritik behauptet dass gerade unter
jungen menschen lesen
verschiedenen formaten besonders populär
ist und zumindest deutlich ausgeprägter
ist als unter älteren sie finden die
details alle im internet guckt man die
jugend an etwa die kim-studie oder in
der schweiz
james studie dann sieht man keine großen
tendenzen gefragt danach ob jugendliche
also 12 bis 19 jährige entweder täglich
oder mehrmals pro woche lesen und hier
geht es nur um das ist ganz wichtig nur
um gedruckte bücher also dazu gehören
keine audio books dazu gehören keine
e-books da gilt zugehört nichts dazu was
irgendwie mit lesen auf dem handy zu tun
hätte und auch da sehen wir eigentlich
die gruppe der intensiven leserinnen und
leser als relativ stabil
genauso wie übrigens auch die gruppe
derjenigen stabil ist die fast nie und
so gut wie nicht liest die etwa bei zehn
bis 15 prozent in den deutschsprachigen
ländern ist also etwas was mit
funktionalem analphabetismus umschrieben
werden könnte
sie muss das sind erstaunlich stabil und
sie ändern sich jetzt nicht durch das
internet wie man annehmen könnte
es könnte man argumentieren ja es ist ja
niemand mehr diese langen texte sie
kennen alle die thesen von niklas karl
und maria wurde von anderen die als
bestseller verkauft werden
von diesem flachen lesen den dass das
langsame tiefe intensive lesen verloren
gehe
und auch hier gibt es eine ganze reihe
von studien die den umgekehrten trend
zeigen dass also hilary mantel und tat
und wie sie alle heißen die
bestsellerlisten um ausmachen
dass diese bücher länger werden und
damit meine ich eben nicht bloß song of
ice and fire als game of thrones das
sehr umfangreich ist und auch junge
männer zum lesen bringt von sehr sehr
dicken büchern also es wird auch länger
gelesen und dicke bücher haben einen
sehr sehr guten markt die klage über das
flache lesen ist zumindest im peewee
frei ich will es mal so formulieren
ich gebe ihnen ein paar beispiele die
vielleicht einige von ihnen kennen
vielleicht eine andere von ihnen nicht
kennen
instapaper immigranten in kanada die mit
vier jahren ins land kam und englisch
gelernt hat wie man idealerweise lernen
könnte nämlich durch das schreiben von
poesie und dieses poesie schreiben für
geburtstage und andere anlässe hat sie
dann sehr bald auch ausgelagert ins
internet und hat dort begonnen ihre
lyrik zu publizieren auf instagram auf
twitter und in anderen sozialen medien
und diese lyrik hat millionen follower
gefunden wenn sie einen der top von ihr
erleben dann müssen sie sich sehr
schnell um karten bemühen das ist
überhaupt kein problem das 2000 menschen
zusammenkommen real zusammenkommen um
die chaos lesungen zu hören
und natürlich haben verlage
einverstanden dass solche codes sehr
interessant sind also werden diese
gedichte aufgedruckt es gibt übrigens
auch mindestens von mir ihren han i von
im ersten gedichtband eine ausgabe in
deutsch und zwar genauer gesagt ist
eigentlich eine zweisprachige ausgabe
und jetzt schauen sie merken handel und
auf der neue band seiner frau es sind
bücher die auf der new york bestseller
liste gelandet sind die in großen
auflagen verkauft werden über 20
sprachen übersetzt wurden und im
deutschen in der zweisprachigen ausgabe
erschienen sind sie sehen genau das was
sybille krämer auch betont hat dieses
komplementäre der digitalen welt mit der
realen welt also der tatsächlich
gedruckten büchern wenn man das als
realität im unterschied zum digitalen
nehmen möchte das funktioniert fast
bruchlos oder man kann sagen ich fast
bruchlos sondern es verstärkt sich
gegenseitig so sehr dass es hier super
stars gibt die mit anfang zwanzig leben
millionenfach ihre lyrik auch verkaufen
können
in praktisch allen formaten kann
diskutieren ob das hochqualitative lyrik
ist oder ich hatte man in einem artikel
als kalender lyrik bezeichnet wie immer
man dazu steht das ist eine lüge die vor
allem von jungen frauen vor allem jungen
frauen mit migrationshintergrund gelesen
wird weil das auch ihre großen themen
sind zurücksetzung in beziehungen
erfahrung von rassismus und die
diskriminierung als frau das sind
wichtige themen und das spricht eben
sehr viele leserinnen vor allem an ein
anderes beispiel durchaus im gehobenen
bereich ist schon green meines erachtens
einer oder nicht nur meines erachtens
sondern wie sie auch an den preisen
durchaus auch in der bundesrepublik
sehen einer der hoch dekorierten jugend
autoren ist schon queen alle seine
bücher sind übersetzt dem ich glaube nur
das letzte jetzt an spielszene reviewed
und weiß ich jetzt schon übersetzt
worden ist alle bücher werden übersetzt
fast alle sind auch verfilmt worden
viele davon erreichen ein publikum aber
sie erreichen es in dem er eben wiederum
komplementär auch im internet unterwegs
ist
zusammen mit seinem bruder hang green
der jetzt auch als schriftsteller
hervorgetreten ist und die in blogs
videoblogs eben erklären was passiert in
syrien bekannt zuerst
weltkrieg oder warum ist es gut nach den
ferien besonders in usa wieder zurück an
die schule zu gehen also aufklärung im
ganz elementaren bereich zu betreiben
und sie sind zugleich aktivisten ich
weiß nicht ob jemand von ihnen mitglied
ist ja also wenn sie das zeigt schon
sehen dann sind sie mitglied der nerd
weiterer wie zb benedict cumberbatch der
schauspieler gehört auch dazu es sind
also vor allem junge leute die sich hier
zusammen tun und unterschiedliche
politische projekte und soziale projekte
betreiben was ihr hier eben sehen ist
dass literatur nicht mehr nur einfach
teil des üblichen für tom
literaturbetriebs ist sondern literatur
ist hier teil einer letztlich digitalen
umwelt die die analoge welt einfach
umschließt und wie eine zweite haut und
gibt es ist einfach selbstverständlich
dass ein auto auch digital ist man kann
das so bis hin zu gespitzt auf den satz
bringen green stadt krass also während
günter grass ein autor ist der den den
deutschen literaturbetrieb braucht um
als autor sichtbar sein so würde man
sagen schon green braucht den
literaturbetrieb vielleicht nur noch am
rande ist einfach teil eine sehr viel
größeren digitalen umwelt in der dieses
schreiben und lesen passiert und das
eben in sehr großer zahl
ein anderes beispiel eher populär
sie haben autorin die als blockerin in
dem fall des mode bloggerin ein
millionenpublikum erreichen und dann
wird das professionalisiert in dem fall
durch verlage die mit einem team dann
beginnen
mit ihrer bücher zu schreiben online sie
haben schon in etwa um was es dort geht
es den vielmehr müssen sie eigentlich
das buch nicht wissen
trotzdem ist es für verlage sehr wichtig
denn diese debüt roman ist ja meisten
verkaufte in der ersten woche verkaufte
die führung an
in der buch geschichte und diese
professionalisierung des
literaturbetriebs macht wiederum
deutlich dass die professionalisierung
die bedingung hat dass das buch und das
lesen digital umfasst es ist also die
digitale umwelt ermöglicht überhaupt
erst diese unglaublichen karriere
die das buch und das lesen ebenso
lebendig machen auf allen niveaus und
damit sie nicht bloß denken es geht hier
um trivialitäten es gibt einen großen
bereich des wieder erzählens klassischer
literatur wie green gables vor allem
natürlich auch der jane austen bücher in
denen junge leute auf twitter oder in
kombination von twitter und youtube
videos oder video blogs die bekannte
geschichte noch einmal erzählen so als
würden sich mister darcy und ließ sie
gerade aktuell twitter nachrichten
schreiben aber es folgt der broadline
die jane austen aufgeschrieben hat und
das ist ein dieser beispiele dafür dass
es durchaus die klassische literatur
enorme millionenpublikum erreicht und
ganz unterschiedliche formen des remix
sind ganz jenseits des etablierten
literaturbetriebs nach sich zieht und
umgekehrt gibt es sehr amüsierte autoren
wert war als reif larsen dessen letzten
letztes buch gerade noch gedruckt werden
konnte aber das neueste eben engines ist
max nur noch auf dem handy gelesen
werden kann weil es um street view
funktionen für seinen sehr sehr
anspruchsvolles kartografisch
inspiriertes schreiben braucht und dafür
gibt es sehr viele beispiele dass also
auch die literatur auch wenn sie ein
winziges segment bildet in diesem
literaturbetrieb das digitale nutzt also
deshalb könnte man die these durchaus
vertreten dass das digitale zuerst ist
es ist die selbstverständliche umwelt in
der buch lesen texte eigentlich heute
leben und der uns bekannte zumindest für
meine generation bekannte
literaturbetrieb ist nur noch ein teil
davon aber zutiefst durchdrungen von der
digitalität und es gilt für das
kulturelle erbe ihr nur ein beispiel aus
eco die cs am grossen schweizer projekt
für die manuskript der schließung vor
allem mittelalterlicher manuskript
kulturen und was sie hier sehen ist an
ihrem rechner kommen manuskripte wieder
zusammen wie sie vor 1000 jahren einmal
zusammen gehört haben aber heute wie sie
rechts an den metadaten sehen längst
verteilt sind nämlich in paris genf und
st petersburg liegen teile dieses
augustinus manuskript und sie werden
hier zusammengeführt und diese
zusammenführung ist nur möglich aufgrund
einer digitalen umwelt dies ermöglicht
völlig verteilte kulturelle ressourcen
wieder lesbar zu machen wie sie
historisch einmal vor etwa 1000 jahren
wirklichkeit waren also die datierung
ermöglicht eine art zeitreise
und deshalb gibt es ja ein großes
deutsche humanities projektteile
schienenprojekt dass vielleicht einige
von ihnen kennen das den großen plan
verfolgt eine zeitmaschine zu bauen
in der man mindestens in die europäische
vergangenheit zurück fahren könnte an
verschiedene orte und ein teil dieser
technologie ist diese technologie die
solche dinge ermöglicht
wie breit das ist das könnte ich jetzt
endlosen ausweiten
vielleicht betreiben einige von ihnen
buch faces andere schreiben fanfiction
und wir reden immer über millionen
publica andere betreiben instapaper die
heute in fashion magazinen auftauchen
oder book tubes es ist praktisch eine
solche kreativität sichtbar und eine
solche variationsbreite des umgangs mit
büchern mit literatur und formen des
lesens die es in dieser form in den ein
oder anderen vorläufern gegeben hat aber
der umfang mit denen diese änderungen
hier greifbar ist dies völlig
einzigartig und so gewinnt das lesen
durch die digitalität und das buch auch
ganz neue ausdrucksformen die vorher
einfach in dieser größe zumindest nicht
sichtbar war
und die frage ist wofür das langfristig
hin denkt sie auch an so etwas wie
selbst publizieren dieses nadelöhr durch
bestimmte verlage zu müssen ist vielfach
oder wird vielfach umgangen nicht bloß
von apple buchs sondern oder kinder
sondern eben von ganz verschiedenen
social reading plattform smava taz und
fanzines lese plattform die können
selbst organisiert sein also indem sie
nur fanfiction die ezb oder bücher
treffen
sie sind selbst organisiert die autoren
schließen sich zusammen völlig neue
geschäftsmodelle andere
gewinnbeteiligung für junge autorinnen
autoren sind hier möglich und die werten
genutzt
natürlich spielen sie werden sich leben
bereich des etablierten fehlt uns nur
selten wahrgenommen aber wenn sie die
silbermond serie und andere
texte sich angucken dann sehen sie dass
sie durchaus hier ein millionenpublikum
erreichen
und es gibt natürlich noch einen anderen
bereich der auch in der statistik des
börsenvereins nicht auftaucht viele
leute haben nicht das klassische
bücherregal im hintergrund sondern sie
benutzen einfach das internet als einen
großen bücherschrank wo sie einfach
gebrauchte bücher selber verkaufen
beziehungsweise kaufen wenn ich
irgendwas interessiert gucke ich muss
das gar nicht bei mir selber haben so
dieses klassische bibliothekarische
eigentums gefühl spielt für viele leute
eine immer geringere bedeutung das
bedeutet aber nicht dass die bücher
nicht gelesen würden und nicht gehandelt
und darüber diskutiert würden sondern im
gegenteil spielt eine große rolle
wir haben also um das zusammenzufassen
eine vervielfältigung des lesens man
kann aber auch sagen eine gewisse
segmentierung des lesens in bestimmte
unter gattungen dass man sich etwa für
die fan fiction harry potter oder vampir
geschichten interessiert also eine hohe
spezialisierung sich leisten kann sowohl
als leserinnen und lesern die auch als
autoren die verlagswelt selbst bisher
staat abhängig von spitzentitel und das
führt auch dazu dass die oligopolbildung
auch in publikums verlagsbereich ähnlich
wie im bereich der wissenschaftlichen
literatur immer weiter zunimmt im
prinzip ist der markt weitgehend
zwischen drei bis vier großen playern
aufgeteilt pinguinen und eines aus
publishing sind einfach welt player und
dann kommt erst mal lange nichts
den bereich es gibt viele neue medien
unglaubliche kreativität aber anders als
in den 90er jahren auch inspiriert von
vielen postmoderne theorien
diese neue ästhetik des schreibens und
lesens die finden sie eigentlich nicht
sondern was es hier gibt es bekannte
formate zu remixen sich auf bestimmte
genres zu vertiefen
aber die vorstellung des ganz anderen
schreibens des interaktiven schreibens
der auflösung der linearität der schrift
und so weiter also diese ganzen vor
allem aus der poststrukturalismus
theorie stammen sind annahmen haben sich
bislang zumindest nicht bewahrheitet
jetzt könnte man argumentieren und damit
komme ich zu meinem zweiten teil wie
sieht's mit den maschinen aus dass dort
die eigentliche änderung kommt und ich
gehe ganz kurz durch diese drei haupt
schichten durch nämlich die autorschaft
was ändert sich in den verlags prozessen
und wie ändert sich die leserschaft
digital jeweils autorschaft digital ich
hab schon darauf hingewiesen diese
social writing social reading ist ein
phänomen das leben riesige dimensionen
hat etwa mit 18 er heute 90 millionen
autorinnen autoren spielt eine große
rolle und sehr viele bücher und
autorinnen ob das nele neuhaus ist oder
jonas winter oder samantha young oder so
super bestseller die auf den deutschen
buchhandel wirklich mehrere jahre an der
ta chef des software kommen aus einer
welt die nur digital zu erklären ist die
mit dem etablierten literaturbetrieb
erst einmal nichts zu tun haben aber
dann den weg zu pinkeln haus und
knabbere und so weiter finden
aber es gibt natürlich viele welten
fanfiction die er ist ein beispiel für
völlig selbst organisiert und die wollen
auch nicht teil des etablierten
literaturmarkt es werden
butt ist die größte falle die nicht noch
kennen hier geht es schon längst
verbucht quer durch alle medien bis hin
zu filmen etwa zwei millionen leserinnen
und leser am tag 100 tausend geschichten
die hier in allen subgenres also der
alpenkrimi im unterschied zu
irgendwelchen mal vor
fan fiction geschichten sie werden
hauptsächlich nicht mehr im buchformat
gelesen sondern tatsächlich auf dem
nato- oder auf dem mobiltelefon und hier
werden stars geboren die dann auch in
der literaturszene millionärin werden
mit anfang zwanzig einer top wäre hier
ein beispiel davor und die
zusammenarbeit mit den neuen plattformen
die netflix ist einfach schon teil der
entwicklung und inzwischen gibt es auch
rabatt als verlag das heißt hier kommt
von der seite jenseits des digitalen
literaturbetriebs völlig neue akteure
hinein die den markt aufmischen und auch
entsprechend irritierend weil sie
überhaupt nicht aus dem etablierten
verlags welt kommen
und die nutzen selbstverständlich
künstliche intelligenz um zb in diesen
100 tausend geschichten pro tag mit
verschiedenen algorithmen verfahren
herauszufinden welche geschichten besten
verdächtig sind also ist ein eigener
bereich der im buchhandel schon längst
eine große rolle spielt schließlich gibt
es natürlich das schreiben von büchern
also ich greife nur aus der literatur
aussagen wissenschaft heraus den erste
von springer geschriebene wirklich
völlig maschinell hergestellte buch über
den stand der edition batterieforschung
gibt es keine menschen mehr drin
die bewertung von manuskripten wird von
verlagen verstärkt
ausgelagert und auch von so genannter
kombi benutzt und die bekanntesten
beispiele sind wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen watson dem es eben 2016
gelungen ist zum ersten mal ein so
genannte self driving journal zu
schreiben also ein fachmagazin im
bereich design das komplett maschinell
hergestellt worden ist und wenn sie es
noch nicht gehört haben gehen sie mal
auf ibm watson die beta dann sehen sie
sofort diese maschine kann mit ihnen
sehr menschenähnlich diskutieren über
praktisch alle themen wie sinnvoll
kindergärten sind oder was spricht für
oder gegen atomkraft
sie können mit ibm watson über diese
themen diskutieren
das funktioniert also hier deuten sich
noch weitere änderungen an die über das
was ich ihnen zunächst dargestellt habe
doch hinausgehen
natürlich betrifft das auch schon die
distribution sie können heute einen
verlag in ihrem wohnzimmer machen
sie brauchen keine lagerkosten mehr der
begriff der auflage ist eigentlich
überholt denn viele standardisierung und
ermöglichen es sofort entweder online
und oder im internet auf html zu
publizieren
das heißt der ganze prozess dessen was
trocken ist komplett online natürlich
gibt es kleine nischen für preisdruck
aber im prinzip ist der vorgang wirklich
vom anfang bis zum ende
digitalisiert und diese volltexte werden
also nicht die dann tatsächlich in der
ehemaligen deutschen bücherei also heute
deutschen nationalbibliothek als
vollständige text sei also nicht bloß
die metadaten angeliefert also müssen
nicht große pipelines nach frankfurt
vorstellen in der die 300
neuerscheinungen die jeden tag auf dem
deutschsprachigen markt erscheinen
bild direkt geliefert werden so die
nächste frage ist dann gibt es neue
druckverfahren jahr sehr wahrscheinlich
werden bücher demnächst als 3d druck
komplett einfach durchgedrückt also mit
dem einband alles komplett das dürfen
wir erwarten
dann gibt es dieses soziale lesen
diskussionen gut wie zb ist nur ein
beispiel sie sehen ich habe hier mal
goethes farbenlehre also ist die
diskussionsforen über goethes
farbenlehre auf der amerikanischen seite
und sie sehen wie unterschiedlich hier
darüber diskutiert wird das kann sehr
umfangreich das kann sehr akademisch
sein
das kann auch einfach im sinne eines
wohlfühlens my favorite james brown sein
es gibt kein kapitel braun braun in
goethes farbenlehre in klammer gesagt
aber es zeigt einfach dass sich menschen
ganz unterschiedlicher herkunft mit auch
der hochkultur beschäftigen
es gibt neue technologien die zum
beispiel wie lösche fitschen erzeugen
das heißt sie haben das buch und was
dann eingespielt wird wenn es zum
beispiel regnet und nacht wird und so
weiter dann hören sie regen oder vor
geräuschen das wird automatisiert
hergestellt und das ziel ist immer
action also dieses eintauchen und
selbstvergessen in geschichten zu
intensivieren
zum beispiel durch audio files und
andere techniken
es gibt es aber auch in einer ganzen
breite des sozialen lebens in dem
menschen tatsächlich zusammenkommen also
bücher treff.de organisiert auch reale
treffen der leserinnen und leser ted
talks gehören ja auch zu diesen die
beides abbilden
also das ist sowohl digital wie analog
aber wichtig ist dass digitale umgibt
auch das analoge das digitale ist das
was zuerst ist gerade auch im bereich
von fan fiction und das geht eben auch
sehr stark bis hin story krebs man sich
angucken soziale randgruppen die
miteinander sprechen und ihre
geschichten austauschen auch in einem
sozial geschützten raum
da gibt es eine große bandbreite also
deshalb da muss man wirklich sehen dass
das ensi diversen filmen ist und ganz
kurz noch zum schluss auch new york
times und andere explorieren und gerade
neue wege des lesens und geschichten
teilen wie etwa diese berühmte
dokumentiere die sich mit displaced
persons mit migration beschäftigen haben
und die können sie auch auf youtube sich
ankommen und die idee ist neue form des
journalismus zu entwickeln also haben
eine ganze reihe von weiteren solcher
videos gedreht die sie mit 3d brillen
angucken können und die frage ist wo
momente topischen reality unser
zeitungslesen vielleicht ersetzen werden
also das kann ich natürlich nicht
beurteilen schließlich nochmal diesen
punkt zu machen
ich glaube dass so was wie swr2 und das
literarische quartett nicht verschwinden
wird
aber es wird ein kleinerer teil eine
sehr sehr viel größeren digitalen
literaturbetriebs sein und man kann
davon sprechen dass es eigentlich dieses
leitmedium des buch und lesens und des
etablierten literaturbetrieb er an
bedeutung verliert positiv gesprochen
kann man von der demokratisierung des
literaturbetriebs sprechen und damit bin
ich auch schon am schluss ist auch zeit
ich glaube mit einem alex am klinischen
zeitalter des lesens in der einfach
maschinen so dicht bei uns ein gewogen
sind in unseren leser alltag in unserem
umgang mit dem mit büchern mit texten
dass wir die maschinen eben vielfach gar
nicht mehr erkennen
die frage ist wie verstehen wir dass aus
dem bereich der kultur soziologie ist
das herrschende theoretische paradigma
das zu sagen wir haben hier ein prozess
der kulturellen vergesellschaftung der
sich intensiviert sowie im neunzehnten
jahrhundert begonnen hat und durch georg
simmel und andere philosophen zum ersten
mal auch beschrieben worden ist
ein anderer ansatz sagt was wir hier
erleben ist eine pop industrialisierung
der kultur das heißt wenige spitzen
autoren wenige spitzentitel wenige
events ziehen fast alle aufmerksamkeit
auf sich und der andere teil wird gar
nicht mehr beachtet das heißt es gibt
eine große masse und einem ganz schmale
picks innerhalb unserer kultur und
ähnliche prozesse finden wir ja auch im
museumsbereich in concert bereichen und
so weiter
ein anderer ansatz argumentiert stärker
von dem phänomen das ist eigentlich eine
fan kultur ist oder teile der
jugendkultur expandiert weit über die
jugend hinaus und unsere kultur sehr
stark von dieser umgang mit büchern
lesen autoren und verlagen zu tun hat
die eben die merkmale hat wie wir sie
seit den beatles und den fan verhalten
das damals erfunden wurden 1 wurde nicht
erfunden es gibt schon bei franz liszt
konzerten schon im neunzehnten
jahrhundert dass das ist aber was
eigentlich fehlt derzeit ist
ein theoretisches modell in der
eigentlich diese umbauten diese
transformation unseres umgangs mit
büchern und lesen tatsächlich
beschrieben werden kann
dann gehen ganz herzlich und stehen
jetzt für fragen auch zur verfügung
vielen dank fürs zuhören